that should be it right that should be
it
are we back
it says we back
there we go what up michael kroll
yeah that's it
okay well that was lame
sorry to everybody dude why why don't
you have a thumbnail now
why oh no here
we back
cool cool cool okay
okay audio's good all right i'm gonna
let people
kind of get back with us
see if that did anything
hey there's something all right
i'm out here yeah what time is it there
35 minutes i would say they usually do
it a little bit early
um so yeah
uh awesome 103 i want to get your hopes
up for a spider-man post credit scene
all right
this is like a puzzle there it is that's
how it connects right there
maybe that is supposed to come out
does that come out
it doesn't say if it comes out or not
thanks
yeah maybe it's just
well i could figure the right direction
because
like that
could be like
this thing is ridiculous
this is ridiculous
yeah you tell me where you see screws
and i'll screw it in
oh that comes off
no i don't take the panel off
that doesn't okay so it's this way
it's right here but but like oh i see oh
yeah it just comes off
damn but how do i put this back on
that doesn't seem right
you stay
so okay
what the heck man
i don't think this is supposed to be
that difficult
but it is all right hold this no because
you get you have to put batteries in it
too
yeah that panel is under here so there
is
yeah they're supposed to be
see how it says like a b be here
evidently we're not smart enough to do
this
but it's under that thing
does anybody have storm breakers
get out
okay wait wait wait what's this
you can no you can't take it off
no the like the wood on top of it
you're supposed to like be able to get
under it
ah oh it's either broken or it's off
yeah somewhere there
there hey battery i bought batteries
specifically for this
forever ago
one battery
how many
apparently yeah we got it with two
it's got batteries all right here we go
battle yeah you get you get storm
breaker
i will have one wolverine claw you guys
want to see my wolverine claws grab the
wolverine clothes
yeah these things are insane these
wolverine clothes
yeah you have to literally put like tips
on these things because they are stupid
sharp that's what i'll be using
i still got range
hey these are like freaking these are
freaking insane
okay so that's in there yeah
wait wait hold on i think
it works don't don't look at that that's
not supposed to be
yet shut up
you're giving everything away
oh you're kidding he's got a snap where
oh you're making it angry
be silent where's the screwdriver
where's the screwdriver shut up
assisto is the power broker you're not
even like i'm not even touching you bro
yeah yeah yeah you gotta turn
now i'm assuming this is a little a step
above but also the speaker is under this
thing
so i'm serving once i put the cap back
on
i don't think a little kid could do this
either that or i'm dumb i'm probably
i'm dumb for those asking whatever
release i'm going to say 30 minutes
it's very loud
all right all right all right all right
we're getting close there's no switch to
turn it on or off which
concerns me
so it's definitely motion activated
because every time i kind of like
move this thing around
around the corner
these have literally like it has to go
under so i have to peel hold this
so like peel this back
there we go that's that's why i'm gonna
get it before
hey okay wait the instructions say
what it does right i mean how to do it
this thing's like look how big it is
it's huge let's see
it's that big
doesn't say anything the other thing no
turn let's try to turn the lights off
let's see just that light
and then maybe that light
oh look at that
this is pretty legit
i guess i'm not i guess i'm not a norse
god
holy crap here
it's crazy right you're holding it
backwards yeah
that's rude yeah you wouldn't have
killed me
uh major casualties flag smashers uh
maybe john walker
but i don't think they'll kill him as
you can see we're having way too much
fun
here all right give me the give me the
give me the little one
yo can i be thor now is this one still
on
no you gotta turn back on
dang i got both what is
thor like takes both he goes
yo
and then i can fight you grab captain
america shield
i'm having way too much
oh look at that
no you have the little one
no give me that you take the little one
that's culture chris from cosmic culture
don't forget to subscribe to him
i clearly had too much fun with this um
we're gonna we're gonna try to put this
guy right here oh
i didn't do it does that look good
we're gonna oh wait chris come back
[Music]
so it's kind of still making noise
it's not stopping i don't know how i
i honestly don't know how to turn it off
hi rocket
hi hello everybody this is rocket
yes i named her after rocket raccoon
she's a little fat kiddie hey
man what you doing what you doing
this is rocket
geez you guys really love to say but not
i'm gonna have to ban that word
i wonder if i could do that now
let's figure out how to ban that word
because that's been every chat
since one division
so let's do that so anyways thanks for
indulging me while i
uh while i opened stormbreaker
it was actually a lot of fun it was a
lot of fun
is everything still up with the stream
or did it go down again like last time
everything looks good good
sorry about that last time
more rocket she uh she
she went away she's a very shy cat i
rescued her
and i think she was abused before
because um she'll only really come
around to me
um
that's just kind of how it is like she's
very skittish when i got her
i just kept her in my room and now
she'll only like really stay in my room
she's getting a little bit better at it
but
she's still pretty
she's still pretty skittish all right
guys
i'd say we got about 23 minutes until uh
until this gets started so uh let's see
here
um
let's see if this works i just banned
that word
i wonder if that'll stop people from
using it
cool
rescue drocket yeah
i do have a cat i actually have two cats
i have a rocket and i have kyrie
um which is named from kyrie from
kingdom hearts
because i love that hey
robbie world what's going on how long i
would say about
20 minutes 20 20 22 minutes well
it depends on when they decide to
release it let's let's do a check right
here
let's go because i definitely don't
think it's out yet
nope uh i would say like
so it's 12 28 for me right now and i
would say probably like
12.50 it's gonna come out
something like that you have some
breaker too yeah so does it turn off
because i just kind of put it there and
it kept making noise
but i guess it's off now i don't know
i didn't read the instructions i don't
know if it said anything about that
uh dylan taylor hey thank you appreciate
that appreciate that
uh i don't know what's what up with the
word i just it gets spammed all the time
and i want that to stop so i
put it in my banned words but i don't
think it'll happen
until um i like start my next stream
so uh who is my favorite adventurer thor
i know i got like iron man and captain
america too thor is my favorite
um he's an actual god like a
and and i love
taiko iti's adaptation of him
um i didn't mind
thor one the god of thunder or
the dark world uh they weren't amazing
movies they weren't the greatest movies
of all time but you know i didn't i
didn't mind them
um i liked them thor was actually
one of my favorite mz movies until
everyone was like everyone hates the
thor movie it sucks i'm like really
why i don't know
no idea why
am i still live because it
am i still live guys
or is my stream stream is disconnected
but i think that's from before
chat's still going so you guys can see
me right i don't have
youtube on my phone's not really working
so i'm wondering if my freaking
no you can't just remove the batteries
well it's not making noise anymore
um well geez now i have to oh my gosh
that is so
loud yes i'm live okay cool cool cool
because uh yeah i don't know what's
going on
okay my internet's working on on my
thing so that works
all right oh it's getting time
here let me pull this back up so people
can say
see guys you really have no idea how
much i mess up in my videos like
i mess up all the time i have to like do
retakes of
everything falcon winter soldier refresh
nope not ready yet
dang there we go okay cool
cool
yeah looks like we love boys all right
cool
my internet in this house is like i hate
it
i hate it but i did just uh
oh crap i need to get rid of that but i
did just um
buy a house i should be closing on it in
like a month
and hopefully excuse me the wi-fi that
house is better because
oh my gosh my wifi goes out like two
times a day
and i don't know if it's the
router or something like i really have
no idea
can i say the intro of your channel's
videos hey what's up everybody it's
warren welcome back to the cosmic wonder
and this is live stream
i hope that works hey sb sapphire thank
you so much i appreciate that
hey ninja myers thank you jay thank you
yes i am live thank you very much
uh ryan rafford i need to get rid of uh
one of these failed wait where is it now
no that's really weird why it's popping
up on my live stream
oh this is it i need to get rid of this
please delete oh no no we don't need to
delete it
private there we go now let's refresh
the youtubes
cool cool cool
i see some people talking about
sponsored videos sponsored videos
help the channel tremendously um
like really like the equipment that we
need uh
in my new house we have a big studio
coming up and that's gonna be fun
because we're gonna be doing some
different videos
um so it's gonna be really cool starter
gaming
thank you so much let's go back to
this uh yeah alan i am excited for armor
wars
you want to see a cosmic gaming channel
so
okay so yeah
so this is where am i at here
so once upon a time
i did this no that's not it cosmic
warren
so so once upon a time i did cosmic
warren
uh this is it
uh i'm going to start doing this again
and i will do
some games on it um it's not going to be
like full-on gaming though
like i'm not just going to sit there and
play fortnite on it but it's going to be
like minecraft and just funny i
i like comedy stuff so i plan to do that
so if you guys want subscribe to my
personal channel
cosmic warren um
how and why did i start my youtube
channel congrats by the way
thank you and thank you for that super
chat bolt up 714
so i've loved
comics and i would say just like the
superhero
community although when i
like when i was younger and like i got
into all this the community was
really just like comic-con
um youtube
wasn't huge
in fact you know it didn't come out till
like 10 years ago right
just making sure it's not out there yeah
like youtube's only about 10 years old
excuse me so uh the community back then
really wasn't anything like it's like
now it's kind of just like online forums
and even when i was a kid uh we still
had dial-up
internet excuse me um because i'm
i'm a little bit older uh i'm 31
not a lot of people know that and i look
very young uh i guess i got good jeans
but um yeah i
i would go to the comic book store and i
would read comments there's one right
by my house it was like i don't know
like three four
five blocks away and uh channel
memberships are coming soon
sorry to interrupt my story i saw
someone ask they're gonna come soon
they're gonna have exclusive content
like
i hear so many rumors and so many
reports stuff like that i'm gonna put
them all on my channel membership so
and i'm not gonna make them like
ridiculously expensive or anything like
that i know some people do that
no like really it's just kind of the
support of the channel and i'll throw
all the rumors out for you i'll do
members only live streams and stuff like
that
paul hansen thank you for that super
chat love your channel
agent empire is this good game series
we've never played it no i never have
played it i don't even know what that's
about but i'll i'll be sure to check
that out
so anyways that's how i started this
channel i just grew up loving
superheroes i read comics um
i'm not gonna say i'm an expert at
comics by any means but i always love
reading comics and i
have collected a decent amount of comics
in my life i should probably
in my new house i'll put them all like
maybe in the background
some uh some framed ones
yo dennis what's up man thanks for that
super chat
whatever happened to this character they
said they would like to see fight
alongside a thor
i don't know man uh i don't know that
was misdirection i don't know if they
actually were
talking about valentina um you know
madame hydra
uh that one actually got me i'm not
really sure about that
but anyways um so it started
about
four uh four years ago
probably i met the stupendous wave he's
a star wars youtuber
um and we started hanging out and when
he told me what he did
i thought it was crazy cool and i had no
idea
like youtube was such a big thing i only
used youtube
like to watch funny videos right and
that's usually like the ones that are
sent to me or like i saw
on like facebook or something like that
um
and then i realized like what the
youtube community was like how big it
was and he did star wars and i loved
marvel and dc and all this stuff and
star wars too so i was like well i would
really like to do that
um so i decided to do that
because i thought well if these other
people are doing it um
maybe i could do it you know maybe i
could
and as it turns out i guess i can
uh but it's all thanks to you guys i
mean i'd be nothing without all of you
i'm just happy people
like my work and don't hate me and i'm
sure there are a lot of people out there
that hate me
uh but to all the all of y'all show up
like you made this really
like really really worthwhile because
like i said like when i was growing up
the
community was like
like you actually had to like do meetups
and stuff and it was just like
online chat forms and stuff like that
like youtube is now like this really
cool place and with things like discord
and stuff like that like
it's really cool um in mk gaming by
moonish
thank you for that super chat again
considering spidey is coming to disney
plus you think there's a possibility
that benham could come too
uh yeah as premier actually yeah i
actually do
um because i don't
does sony have anything that they put
their movies on
i'm not sure they do that may be a good
strategy for them
to put to do venom i'm assuming since
they got spider-man and like some
characters with spider-man
uh venom would be there too do you think
they will reboot charlie cox is
daredevil or keep his netflix season
canon
um
i know there's a lot of debate around
this
but i don't think kevin feige is going
to keep any
of like the defenders
all those shows uh i don't think he's
gonna keep them
not that they were like really canon
before i don't think he's gonna have any
of those shows be canon
like i don't even think agents of shield
is going to be canon
i i just i just don't think so
hey wait dennis i just got your message
did i not answer it i totally answered
it
oh you're saying like don't have the
answer to it like you're saying yeah i
mean
i don't know if we i don't know if
there's a secret cameo coming
because when when the producer said
there's a character that they would love
to see be with thor i'm thinking like a
godlike character like a character that
has like incredible power
it's definitely not madame hydra
somebody said something like a valentina
her name is bao
referring to valkyrie i don't think
that's it um
i think i don't want to start the rumor
mill
because it's not even a rumor it's just
me thinking i i i you know maybe
we see the cameo here uh i don't know
it's like
because we only really got introduced to
her there's no one else
so i mean
that one baffled me um because i don't
think
people would really want to see
valentina madam hydra with thor
that doesn't make any sense to me so
maybe he was trolling us
like paul bettany did or maybe he
actually you know
um yeah we're gonna get another cameo
i don't think it's old cap because we've
already seen them together like
all throughout the mcu all right let's
look
it's uh 12 41.
and it's not out yet we're gonna keep
looking
nike boy boy he's 23
assuming 23 is for jordan right on i
love michael jordan um
thunderbolts john walker there's a lot
to talk about i would really love for a
thunderbolts post credits scene
are we gonna get it i don't know
uh i don't know
i mean it's marvel they can come up with
all the stuff they want to but like what
else would they do for a post credit
scene
that would set something else up in the
future um
i'm sure sam and bucky are going to
be a part of other upcoming things
no doubt about that so they could tease
us for something
like about that but i've heard for some
some people
and these people are right and wrong
sometimes
so it's like i don't know
i i i you know they say the thunderbolts
coming is what i'm getting at
but but their track records are like
kind of they're right sometimes they're
wrong sometimes
and we've been having rumors about the
thunderbolts for like a very long time
and based on them on everything that
i've seen i truly
i think they're coming and i want this
post-credits scene
for this finale maybe they'll give us
two right want to vision give us two so
let's let's hope the games too
um i would like one of them to be
the raft um the dora malagio last
episode took
zemo to the raft and
that's controlled and ran by thunderbolt
ross and it's prison
you know for some maximum security
prison in the middle of the water in the
middle of the ocean
for very very
uh violent
i'm trying to what's the word i don't
know uh
just villains right like dangerous
villains
and i want thunderbolt ross to walk into
the raft
i want to see some other
villains in the raft and then he goes
and like goes to zemo
and when he goes to zemo he says
something like
so you tasted a little bit of freedom
how'd you like to really be free and
just you know
kind of like you know like you lead my
team probably just even like how'd you
like to really be free
right because the stipulation is going
to be joined by thunderbolts team or
it's going to be
you know lead my team something like
that so
all right let's refresh 44 the episode
could be out soon
sometimes they're early they're not
early right now
nope not yet
let's uh make sure
test test test test test yep everything
looks good to go
gonna have to mute the desktop audio
what is this i don't even know what this
is i have to meet
this test test test test test yep you
still hear me
cool
am the best hello from bangladesh hello
from america i
saw some people uh uh asking
where i'm from i live in america audit
grew wall i'm sorry if i couldn't
pronounce it right when i take the serum
you know i would um
you know it's like
dr erskine said it
it brings the good out in you if you're
good
or if you're bad it brings the bat out
right um
before i kind of got a lot of people i'm
kind of partially disabled
it's hard for me to walk sometimes but
before that i used to do
bodybuilding and my coach wanted me to
take steroids and i never would
and one time i'm like dude all these
side effects blah blah blah
and i'm like and doesn't make you like a
douche bag aren't you like angry all the
time
and it's like nah if you're a douche bag
it's going to make you more of a
douchebag
if you're a nice person it's not going
to be a problem that's kind of like
super soldier serum and it's almost
kind of the same thing not really right
steroids and super slow serum it's uh
easy
real life in movies right like what i
wish could be real
but um what happened if a mutant took
the serum
that's a good one i like what happens it
well i guess wolverine really is
kind of i mean he's a weapon x uh
product i will say but what happens if
like jean grey took the super soldier
serum like
oof like professor x takes the super
soldier serum
and all of a sudden he can walk and
stuff like that because of the serial
number man that'd be crazy cool man
that'd be
it'd be crazy cool uh
hey luke thornton i appreciate that yeah
you know it's hard you know to do uh
to do scripts and stuff like that um
i don't actually make scripts
i have bullet points that i talk about
when i when i do my videos like
i'll just put like depending on the
video
um i never plan for how long's uh
a video is going to be comic exposed
what's up again
uh red hulk will be in this episode yes
or no i want to say no
um and i don't know if you just joined
but um
i'm hoping there's a thunderbolt ross
post credit scene where he's at the rapt
and he's recruiting um
and he's recruiting zemo
and like other people that's what i hope
is gonna happen uh
i don't know if it's gonna happen but i
really hope so
um yeah
but i don't script my videos i just have
bullet points
and i'll go through each one and i'll
talk about it and i'll like kind of talk
off the top of my head
and then i'll stop gather my thoughts
and then i'll talk um it's not like i
don't really like sit there and write a
whole script
unless i have like really really really
really thought about a theory like
in-depth
um thank you for that super chat
dilly248 are the cosmic winner signs for
sale
uh not yet um that was given to me by
one of my best friends
for this past christmas because i've
been talking about making one for so
long like for when i finally started
live streaming
because i you know that wasn't really
live streaming before these shows came
out
and you got it from me so uh merch is
coming
though it's actually kind of being
designed right now
um i'm trying to make merch that's like
not like just my logo and stuff like
that like cool shirts that
you know are from you know the shows and
the movies and stuff like that
hey bug master 846 thank you for that
super chat i appreciate that
louis joey thanks for the sticky for
that super chat super appreciate that
uh did i miss any i hope i didn't miss
any super chats
12 49 it might come out
might come out in one minute
nope not out yet maybe one minute
they've been
decent at uh being early
where are you i'm refreshing it's not
there
let's exit all of this let's bring this
up
what are my visa morbius um i'm really
excited for it
and i hope it connects i hope it
connects like spider-man and venom and
other movies
all right boys it's out we've about to
do this
one world one people 52 minutes you're
only giving us 52 minutes
ah levity jacks all right
are you all ready if you're starting
with me three
two one let's go
previously on the falcon and the winter
soldier
so oh let me widescreen for everybody
would you join the mcu if so who would
you be um
if i had to be somebody that was already
existing nathan meyer saying
that super chat i would be thor if not i
would like make
cosmic wonder a character bolt up sorry
about your disability
glad your channel is successful you
deserve it i appreciate that that's hard
but um
the condition i have actually it could
be a lot worse so i'm pretty blessed in
that
hey thank you pugmaster i appreciate
that it should be out pretty soon
i appreciate that merch will be out soon
so they're just recapping guys
right now there's bar truck and we are
going let me make sure i have my stream
pulled up here
so i can uh
excuse me if anything happens i don't i
want to be able to know
all right
here we go i obviously can't show the
whole thing
but i'll show you as much as i can and
i'll
try to make it a little bit bigger
marvel studios
all right
all right so we're starting with carly
it's just carly and some of the other
flag smashers
oof
oh that guy's in a helicopter
here it is just so you know we're
talking spoilers in this one so uh watch
out for that
complete lockdown at the grc
all right so this grc is a complete
lockdown right now
but they're stuck in the room right now
all right so the question is oh is that
red wing
or is that just him
all right so buggy's on site oh
the security just let him through
interesting
i called this a backup who is this
no way that's awesome
so sharon's here with him now dang
oh falcon's here oh and carly sees
falcon
he's here do it now do what now
throwing grenades and stuff into the grc
look at that gas into the grc
so sharon had a cloaking device that
changed what she looked like
it was almost like she was a scroll
maybe she is a scroll
interesting oh these people are trying
to leave
oh he's got the shield oh he threw it in
the air
no way dude that is freaking
epic look at that suit
oh
no way
he said who are you it says that i'm
captain america
that's amazing
bar truck
how much can i get for your new bird
costume
here's bucky and sharon coming don't let
the flag smashers out of the building he
says dude
holy crap that suit's amazing
oh there's that scene from the trailers
people are evacuating
i'm dude when sam said i'm captain
america how freaking cool was that
carly's up to something she's talking
with other people and here goes bucky
oh carly's on the phone for her him
interesting
what's gonna happen here
oh she's trying to recruit him
she says it doesn't matter if i don't
survive this
interesting sam says you don't think
i've tried to fight for stuff
bigger than myself that's all i've tried
to do and i failed twice
mk gaming thanks for super chat yeah
like all this and all of a sudden
freaking five minutes not even
is it five minutes i don't say it's five
minutes because like the recap doesn't
count right
all right so they're evacuating
everybody right now
uh they're in a oh no just are they the
people they're gonna
blow up they're so they just put all
these people
in the police convoy oh he's locking it
yeah oh he put the bomb on it
yeah this guy just put a bomb on it oh
sharon come on sharon do stop
do something yeah these guys are like
these guys are sitting ducks this dude's
locking them into the thing and putting
like explosives on them
yeah look at that you just put like this
thing on whoa
check this out
dude it's so cool seeing sam with that
that suit in the shield
uh episode's 52 minutes long for people
asking
bucky's talking to carly saying don't go
down this path
and she said if that's how you feel you
should sit this one out
all right here we go
this big who's this big dude he was
working for those flag smashers but
i gotta wonder
sharon said seriously bucky had one job
she put something on him
sharon just put something on this guy yo
this is awesome so far
oh bucky on the motorcycle what up
he's straight up gonna jump off here's
sharon
oh she got the car that's awesome oh she
freak
oh she straight up murdered this guy
mercury vapor holy crap
all right so they're taking people out
in the helicopter now which i'm pretty
sure
is being piloted by a flags measure yeah
that's a flag
sam is fighting bar truck
sharon said the helicopter's about to
take off and sam's like bucky come on
buggy's like i don't fly that's your
thing
falcon fighting without the shield look
at that dude oh my gosh
come on sam come on sam kick it up like
captain america
he kicked it up like captain america
oh andy uses jet pack to freaking thrust
himself forward with the shield
here we go boom oh no
oh that's so sick
i'm liking i'm liking the shield and
wings combo
oh and it just sits on his back as he
flies that's epic
boom go get him go get him sam
he's chasing the chopper right now with
the shield on his back
check this out
don't shoot sam that's
the helicopter propellers hit sam
he got red wing back boom baby
but good thing he's got those vibranium
freaking wings
just examined a person i don't know who
that was i'll have to go back and check
that out
yeah you're thinking only about mc
appreciate that
suited widow breaks yeah the suit's
awesome where's casino kill the hostages
carly's getting serious
carly says it doesn't matter if we die
movement strong to continue without us
dang carly's getting like freaking
deep here man
one world
carly's people are turning on her
so carly said kill your hostages and
stuff like that
and uh it's clear that they don't want
to do the other flag smashers don't want
to do that
that's nypd helicopter coming to help
salmon them
oh that's that's got to be sharing
oh no way
dude that's crazy cool look at that
that's crazy cool
no sam just covered that guy with this
no way look at that look at that oh
people are cheering for him oh yeah oh
sam is totally the new captain america
that better be official by the end of
this episode
oh my gosh
all right these uh here come the flag
smashers are gonna go kill the hostages
right now oh dang
oh no
oh she hijacked the
yeah red wing just straight up rescued a
guy while sam rescued the other guy oh
here it comes here comes the bucky
oh yeah you're gonna get it buddy
oh
hell yeah bucky
we need a diversion give him somebody to
rescue
no they're freaking lightened the people
on fire there it is
wow they let one of them on fire
come on bucky come on bucky come on
bucky
come on bucky get him out
that guy put that thing on the back of
it oh
he came in saying mor morgentha let's
finish this
she said i didn't mean to kill your
friend i don't want to hurt people that
don't matter
throw it john
yeah that's not the same shield
get him john i don't like it that much
but i want you to beat all the flag
smashers
oh bucky can't break the thing oh no
he's breaking it he's breaking it
come on bucky come on buggy
yeah get him out bucky come on john dude
oh that shield's cracking
oh that shield's not holding
oh john's getting the crap beat out of
him
there's his medal oh that he sees on the
back
come on john you can do it
it's not the same [ __ ] as all oh they're
gonna pull that thing out of the ground
bucky you gotta save john walker now and
bucky saves john walker
oh
it's going to town
come on bucky you're stronger than her
let's go
boom
meanwhile falcon's still trying to take
the helicopter down
[ __ ]
come on falcon do something
put in your earbuds
yo that's epic sam was communicating
oh falcon falcon's down in the water can
he get out of the water
birds don't really swim very well
as it turns out falcon can't get out of
the water
go red wing
oh snap here we go two
one oh snap no
and then she gets in the and then she
gets in the seat no way
that was epic
wow okay that was
that was freaking awesome he threw the
shield
broke the door grabbed the shield flew
through the cockpit took out the driver
and then the girl in the back
is driving all right john come on i need
to just step it up
i need to step it up john
there we go john yeah
[Applause]
avenge lamar avenge lamar
come on john
oh oh she just kicked him and he just
took it like it was nothing
come on dude oh he pissed
oh he pissed
come on avenge him don't kill her just
to bench him though
thanks she got him she kicked him down
brick
all right john come on you can do it get
up meanwhile bucky is freaking
oh oh no
dude oh car
carla just threw that truck i think into
the ocean
oh that's not good
is bucky about to catch this truck
oh snap john you're there what you gonna
do
is your chance man redeem yourself
oh he chooses go after carly or save the
people he's gotta choose
you know what to do john you know you
gotta save the people
yeah oh he threw away the shield
yeah that shield crumbled and john
walker saves the day
people redemption
oh they're trying to get him up no leave
him alone he's trying to save the people
they are falling oh they're falling did
somebody catch them
who caught them who caught them
who is it is it sam
yeah oh that's sick
oh that's awesome look at that
wow he's got two red wings
well i guess they always split off into
more didn't they
come on sam push it up push it up and
walker's watching
walker's gonna fight with him now come
on yeah
oh everyone's watching everyone's
watching the recording
that's captain america yes
dude this is so good okay wait carly's
coming
oh no
oh this is about to be a crazy cool
scene john walker bucky and sam fighting
together
no way
people are uh oh this is new oh
this bar truck
and sharon
dude what is
what is happening so bar truck just came
and gave the flag smasher some guns
but sam has thermal vision
dude john walker's working with sam and
bucky now no
way i love it i i love it
so they're talking to sharon which i
don't think is a good idea
and here they split up
so uh bucky and john walker together
what's the plan here
oh there's sam captain america
coming to fight carly
well here's bard truck bar trucks
creeping in trying to kill sam
and what is this carly yeah carly with
the gun coming
oh
sharon carter tells carly to drop her
weapon
look at this what's happening
who is she who are you
is she the power broker
then she's power broker
sharon is the power broker
she's about broker
i knew it
yeah you hired bartrack to spy on me
bar truck says you'll pay me four times
what you
or i'll tell the whole world who you are
dude no way
oh oh who shot who
sharon's shot that's not good
don't don't kill sharon
dude sam looks so freaking cool
oh and it's sam versus carly now
sam says i'm not gonna fight you
oh no way he used his wings to ground
him oh this is epic
look at him fight oh no
oh she said stay down i thought he was
gonna say i could do this all day
who are they meet these people are
meeting someone
the other flag smashers are meeting
people
they're meeting captain america and
bucky well not captain america john
walker and bucky
sam is captain america now
yeah y'all are gonna survive a bunch of
bullets you're super soldiers but you
can't survive a bunch of bullets
[Laughter]
meanwhile falcon and carly falcon's not
fighting her
he's not fighting back
she's just yelling at him to fight him
and he's not fighting
oh no the shield
and she picks up the gun and what's she
gonna do
you're not gonna shoot sam oh you know
what i bet you she does
but he's got vibranium armor on
yep she's gonna shoot him oh no
oh sharon shot her
dude oh
guys spoilers guys in case
you know this is a watch party spoilers
oh no
oh no
dang
oh no he's carrying her out
didn't think they were gonna i didn't
think that was gonna happen
got all the people waiting
oh man i didn't that's freaking epic
dude that is freaking
brick that's so cool
gosh that looks so cool
and then freaking john walker actually
becomes good at the end of the freaking
day
look at that
f for carly in the in the chat
what do we call usage still packing or
is a captain falcon
sam's talking some truth to them
dang sam's just saying we have to stop
calling these people terrorists
and you can't send the refugees back
have a black man carrying the stars and
stripes but don't i understand
dang
oh oh is isaiah watching yeah he is
epic epic
sam says i'm here no super soldier serum
no blonde hair no blue eyes
the only power i have is i believe we
can do better
oh dora's
the news is live cast and sam yep
dude is steve watching his sister's
watching
oh
dang
dang sam's freaking basically telling
them they have to
they have to change because you know the
flag smashers believed in
and good and imagine the next flagsmash
are stepping up
look at that little nod to john walker
these guys are hilarious
he caught him cap
bucky caught him cap and here's sharon
sharon carter
he said uh cap and he said i think he's
talking to you
who's who called him
who just called him
who's this i don't who are you
so he said i got news on the
on the other flag smasher can you help
always
okay so oh what's this
so they're take
so they're taking oh they're
transporting the flag smashers to the
raft
where thunderbolt ross is
of course one of these that guy just
said one world one people
so they're you know
oh dang there's a blow up
who's this who is this
oh no way draft
zimbo where's ross where's ross
oh valentina
oh walker's there
oh that was zemo's
like butler guy
so valid so so
zemo's looking for valentina i don't
think so
oh oh oh he's getting a new outfit
oh and us
agent boom look at that
dude that's super comic accurate
we're not gonna need a captain america
we're gonna need
a usa jit
look at that
he says i'm back i'm back i'm back i'm
back u.s
agent oh no he's going to talk to yuri
bucky's going to he's going to make
amends with yori how's yori your gonna
take it
oops what did i do
he's knocking on yori's door
[Music]
oh
so what are you doing here it's not
wednesday there's the sun
oh man i have to tell you something got
spoilers by the way it's
about your son
oh look he took off the
he was murdered
by the winter soldier
and that was me
i didn't have a choice he already said
why
he said i didn't have a choice
oh he left
dang doctor
something dr raynor oh it's dr raynor
someone left her a little a little gift
oh it's the book with everything crossed
out look at that
what does this say i finished the book
thanks for all your help doc
and then sam again is he gonna go see
ori again
or is he gonna go see the girl he went
on a date with
what's he doing here both of them
dang
and then back here to isaiah's house
what you want black falcon
he ain't a falcon anymore but he's still
black
that's it says i saw what you did right
there out there
everybody else did as well
making a men's leg
oh he says i ain't gonna lie you're
special
you ain't no malcolm or martin that's
funny
i know what i gotta do
okay so black captain america oh you're
dang right
dang
hmm
sam i'm not gonna let anybody tell me i
can't fight for the country
[Laughter]
hahaha
there's something i want to show you
interesting
hey oh no way did they add his thing in
there
they're gonna add his uh
no way that's
they're going to the they're in the cat
museum
no way he's get there he's going to have
something written about him
oh he's holding this look at that
oh no way that's too cool
a memorial for him
isaiah bradley
that's awesome
that's awesome
now they'll never forget what you did
for the country
oh epic epic
oh dang he's shaking
look at that that's awesome
all right we're uh in credits or
nope we back in new orleans and
everybody's
uh britain excuse me
even bucky's there
they hanging off his arm hanging off his
arm like that
[ __ ] is so cool
what is that oh
and there it is
is this it meet the post credits
or the end credits and then post credit
scene
okay okay okay okay okay okay
that was it title card where
all right come on post credits where are
you
oh okay
getting to the post credits right here
getting to post credits
sharon carter and court
we repay some of the debt that is owed
to you
we'd like to offer you a full pardon
welcome home agent carter
look at that no way
amk gaming well thanks for that super
chat yeah i uh
oh no she's still evil
is she still evil
she is still bad
oh no sharon's still
evil yeah the isaiah's saying the isaiah
scene
mk gaming that was that that shook me up
too that was pretty cool
with the uh with the memorial to him all
right there's gotta be another post
credit scene no there's not
is there just one wait no go back
no don't play one division
you didn't even show me the end credits
so there's only one post credit scene
stop
doing that go back i don't play one
division
whoa
oh my gosh
wow what a finale
all right
well dang
wow um
wow okay um let's start
doing all the stuff we need to do for
the um
for the zoom
getting in a zoom call hi it's chris
what
uh if you want we can do discord right
now
if i can figure out how to do that um
here we go yo like wow
wow okay i need this
hi dude can you not do the you don't you
can't do the video can you
how dare you
wow um wow
hold on let me make sure audio is
working
wow oh hold on they can't hear you
i think we're good now though
should be all right i'll be here
talk chris
did i get it work is it working it
should be all right
can y'all hear chris
can y'all hear chris diego perez thanks
for the super chat you thought one of
his vision was better
i thought it was different it's hard to
judge the two of them to
be the same thing because they're really
not uh but i enjoyed falcon i want to
soldier more but hey
teach their think own the time
hold on fast don't think they can hear
you
here i have a better idea hold on
uh well that wasn't working so let's try
this
hello i know i think this should be
better
well okay
guys thoughts one division or the falcon
underwear soldier
not to the whole thing what do you mean
well until i had the whole storyline it
wasn't like three episodes and i was
like yeah falconer
but once i got to the end
interesting i um
i still can't hear you
oh yeah you can hear you just very low
i'm gonna turn you up more
uh yeah i don't know you're turned up
all the way
well i enjoyed the falcon in the winter
soldier a little bit more because
i liked
i liked the action um i feel like it was
a very in-depth story not that one a
vision wasn't because obviously it
really was um
yeah i don't you don't really have to
choose you know
you know that's the great thing about
everything we don't have to choose what
we like more we can like
everything
yeah to me they were
very very different um they were very
different shows
yeah it really is apples and oranges i
mean like
one division was so different and
the falcon winter soldier was more
marvelous um
wha okay how about that freaking
sharing carter scene at the end
is the power broker we freaking called
it
i'm gonna go back and find it where we
called it so if anybody
doubts and it was just you and me on the
phone at the time we were just sitting
there like you know what
she had a problem this is something she
has to be the power broker that
coupled with your interview with the
director yeah yeah
when i yeah it's interesting
um it is interesting to see sharon be
the power broker and then at the end be
pardoned
and then and still evil
um
she very much could be done with the
government yeah
and she's like yeah i'll work for you
guys
uh maybe valentina
maybe sharon and valentina were
working together uh usage
at the end in the super comic
accurate costume like wow
they actually did a really good job with
falcons too
he that blew me away the shield
and falcons shoot the falcon suit blew
me away
you know i would s
again uh
again you don't really have to choose
i'm not sure
so so one of vision i feel like was this
whole roller coaster of
when the ex
[Laughter]
right it was totally our fault it was
like totally my fault
and uh other people uh you know
you know in the community for all of us
talking about
uh um mephisto showing up
and i i would say the one thing i was
really worried about with the falcon and
winter soldier
was i is one of thunderbolts because we
didn't get crap
although i'd be really surprised if if
it
if they don't show up in the mcu soon i
i would be really really surprised i
it would be a very big waste um
uh for those asking the old guy that
blew up the car was working for zemo
it's the guy that uh
yeah it was like his butler yeah
yeah right totally and uh he killed all
the
he killed all is that oh i mean except
for john walker
right so one of them still alive so
who was that
yeah so so
was sharon helping
falcon and sam just so she could get
pardoned just so she could still be evil
i don't know i mean did she just have so
much faith that sam wasn't gonna die
who is the guy they zoomed in on when
the flag smasher car blew up
maya deeb that was um zemo's
butler that's what we'll call him um
uh comic suppose super chat always
coming up with super chats uh
you didn't like it i liked it um i did
uh uh i don't know how long sam will be
captain america for um
i would actually like to see bucky
become captain america at one point in
time
or maybe steve's kids uh
you know i i'm still not sure
where steve in this whole timeline
you know because the writer said that
steve was always the parents
of uh peggy's kids in the photo
from civil war um but then the rooster
brother said no it's a different
timeline and based off like loki coming
up
i would say yeah it's like disney disney
has
you know different timelines um i think
i enjoyed falcon and we're soldier more
than one division
um but again they're very very different
and we don't have to choose
i think thunderbolts are for sure still
in the picture no matter what even
though they didn't show them here
yeah i just i think that the um
the shows do a really good job at like
focusing on what the shows are about
and then and then they're gonna announce
like the thunderbolts
shows coming right and it's gonna and
then that that's we'll do like the
backstory we'll see flashbacks of
everything
that's what they do baby boy thanks for
super chat
no they're not just gonna throw it at us
you know
they really are what if black people
wait she's dead
rip oof thanksgiving uh diego perez i
think look would be the best disney plus
series dude i think so too
i'm like really really excited for that
one that's what i've been saying is
gonna be my favorite
i bet uh i i i think that's gonna be
hard to mess that one up um
yeah you know you wonder
you know
no and i think as much as i liked these
shows
i think better is to come oh it's only
going i mean loki is gonna be
loki's gonna kill it
maybe yeah it would make sense of loki
connected to thor 11 thunder it really
would all of these shows
well speaking of that speaking of that
joe cr carrizo thank you for the super
chat how does the whole fight in new
york happen and no doctor strange and
spider-man show up
so i think they're dealing with
uh no way home stuff right they might be
in another dimension or something
thank you for that super chat yeah i
i think awesome super chats real quick
so uh not missing them
uh it's brandon
my favorite part was the first look at
usage thanks for that huge super chat
appreciate that
yeah that was really cool wasn't it that
was like
super comic accurate and what and she
said it which was cool to me
right she she said u.s agent we don't
need another captain america you know we
need us agent that's me was really cool
cole troya uh i think i pronounced it
right i hope so if not i apologize
uh appreciate that super chat james look
is too predictable
uh i mean i didn't expect the bad guys
to win um i didn't expect sharon carter
to stay bad
um i guess it's like you know she kind
of got the taste of being bad and now
and it kind of jumps away i wasn't
expecting carly to die i know some
people predicted that
that's honestly not something i was um
predicting
so people asked me at the beginning and
i was like
kill him yeah
uh good good point casey mcnatt and
thanks for that super chat anybody
noticed that bal
referred to zemo as a friend yeah i
think
um i think someone like zemo
and someone like val definitely always
have their connections right
uh uh yeah um
i'm i'm thinking zemo's not staying in
in the raft
in prison and i'm i'm thinking that the
thunderbolts are going to come
yeah yeah two seconds devin schwerz
thank you for that super chat super
appreciate that
um appreciate the words uh yeah no um
um
yeah he dropped his stupid [ __ ]
i was like dude he dropped his
dude use guns
john like don't make a makeshift captain
america shield
use guns you have you're a soldier you
know
right and that was a really cool thing
about john walker he had a total
redemption arc
i'm and he looked at carly and he looked
at the people about the fall
and he's thought i can kill carly or i
can save these people and he saved the
people and he kind of like shook his
head like trying to get the stupid
thoughts out of his head you know
and he did he made the right decision
because he
right because he was a hero before like
he was actually a hero before
so you know and it's good to see that
redemption art
uh they definitely set up the
thunderbolts also same as our new cap i
know
garrett uh gutierrez
dude when he said i'm captain america
that was so cool
that was so cool yeah uh bradley jones
super chat i knew the scene with bucky
and yori would happen but it's just so
heartbreaking yeah it was
and uh yeah but man i i wanted more from
that scene that's where i'll say i was a
little disappointed
i wanted more from that scene
that's kind of true too i mean uh
you know the sun sets on [ __ ]
yeah right uh comics disposed why am i
sharing a bad guy what's the point
um you know i'm kind of wrapping my head
around that uh to be honest i
not sure i can tell you the point i i
really like all i can say
is that i'm i'm sure there's a plan here
like clearly there's a plan
i think she's like the new hydra
infiltrating um
yeah oh my gosh this is funny rachel
knight online thanks for the super chat
wow steve really barry allen things
went back in time instead of going back
and not because hit his knees he ended
up turning her to a super villain bruh
that got me okay that's a good one thank
you for that super chat
it's very true um i gotta acknowledge a
bunch of super chats chris
uh hey zeus meza
is it going to be a second season we'll
lead to something else uh as far as we
know right now it's gonna lead to
something else oh and thank you for
super chat
um not a season two confirmed yet um but
they pretty much said like
it's possible um i think this will lead
into other movies
um troy reynard
renerd sorry i didn't pronounce it right
now at home will tie into this probably
by the end
like when spidey comes home and sees sam
on the news yeah totally um
i think so because i don't see how it
doesn't does that make sense
and thank you for that super chat john a
b thank you for that super chat how does
spiderman or doc strange not show up
from home is still two months away in
the timeline so we know he's not busy in
europe yet
actually um they both take place six
months after
end game uh chat correct me from wrong
but i believe
that's correct um from what i remember
and i bet you they're stuck in like a
different dimension or dealing with
their own stuff right
um because i'm pretty sure they would
they would think of that king jay
um thank you for that super chat wait
just to make it clear is an old man
steve from a different timeline if so
how did he get there
and was he in falcon in the winter
soldier so they weren't
too clear about this right um i mean old
man steve
he's originally from i'll call it our
timeline the main timeline
um but then he went to he created a
different timeline
right and then he came back to our
timeline so we don't know if he went
back if he stayed in ours and he died
like we really don't know um i thought
we'd get some closure about that but uh
they didn't
oh i missed the super chat uh
okay uh mellow b got a theory not
regarded falcon winter soldier thanos
the sword is missing maybe someone like
carter
would take it and use it to make
adamantium for the wolverine that would
actually be pretty cool
um it'd be like uber metal and uh uh
a wolverine which make him even tougher
uh thank you so much that super chat
that's a great thought good theory i
really i really like that a lot
shane martin photo what do you think
carter was referencing when she said
government secrets and weapons
what's she going to be after um i think
she might just be selling secrets
um i think that's kind of what she does
she's a broker
right a power broker and she gets people
things that
they want so i think she's gonna be
selling secrets selling weapons all this
stuff um
and i'm really surprised that she's bad
like i
i'm wrapping my head around it because i
i don't really
get it i know i i don't bolt up i don't
know why you can't hear him but we're
about to join the zoom and that should
be better
ty seal elijah bradley was given a lot
of screen time setting up
younger bridges even more definitely
thanks to super chat especially at the
end there right he was given a lot more
screen time
um a lot a lot more springtime bradley
reed do you think sharon carter's a
scroll
no no i think i think that's her
um no i really think that was sir all
right we're gonna jump
in uh the zoom call now uh chris go
through the zoom call because maybe
they'll hear you there
there yeah just leave the uh
thing huh mr spooky spare thanks for
that uh border combat is here yeah
if he created a new timeline how come
the tva ain't coming after him like loki
uh yeah i don't know maybe because he
was like trying to do good thinks that
super chat again
and if i didn't say it uh mr spooky
spare thanks for that super chat
um channel the great so what the
aluminum foil type of metal shield to
shoot agent heaviest but that's so funny
thanks for that super chat
all right hold on hey
yo what is up
the finale hold on let me get the boys
on screen here
uh i gotta how do i do this let's uh
brad what's up man yo what do we think
yeah i liked it a lot i uh
i'm feeling really good i loved it um
i really did i really did sorry let me
fix my screen so everyone can see the
boys
please there we go
guys holy crap like okay first of all
[ __ ] suit amazing
was literally just thinking amazing
maybe other than maybe an iron man suit
i would agree with you
hey can we just yeah real quick
the scarlet witch outfit and now this
oh yeah oh marvel's stepping it up bro
so guys real quick quick cuz i just got
a super chat thank you to uh
channel the great he said so what in the
aluminum foil type of
shielded ush
[Laughter]
sorry that's pretty good so
i yeah right i bet you the shield that i
have right here
is stronger than the shield
for real the little kid toy halloween
costume
uh shields are stronger than that that's
freaking hilarious
yo guys i wanna know what you think
about [ __ ]
dude oh man favorite part of the episode
had to be oh there were so many good
parts
honestly when falcon came in with the
suit for the first time
and he said i am captain america
that part yeah
yeah i thought captain america is on the
moon
uh what about you guys what about you
guys
oh yeah yeah yeah such a powerful
episode from top to bottom but yeah i
mean
when sam shows up in the outfit for the
first time yeah
comes through the window yeah
this is awesome
and there came an opportunity when they
were kind of like sitting down and like
you don't know what it's about like you
don't understand how complicated he took
a second
the writing for this show spectacular
dude it felt like a tv show like it
really felt like a tv show
and they wrapped it up perfectly
yeah dude that was it was 52 minutes
long but that was like the longest 52
minutes of my life like it felt like a
movie
uh hold on guys i'm trying i guess i'm
having audio problems i'm not
the chat's not hearing you guys which is
a problem
um i'm going to leave and come back on
my other pc and hopefully that'll fix
it because that's not we can't have that
but uh boys on my end i gotta get out of
here but i appreciate all of you
hey no problem dude yeah this was
this is awesome we do love you
yeah for sure all right hold on let me
let me let me leave and be right back
i'm trying guys i'm trying uh
give me a second let me get these guys
in here
because we got lots of talking to do and
uh don't worry i i am going to get to
the super chats
i took screenshots of them so they don't
so they go away
matthew king sharing gonna sell stuff to
norman osborne how cool would that be
right i mean
really that would be cool thank you for
that super chat
uh trying to get this open here
uh i guess i can't
crap hold on
i never have problems in the finale i'm
gonna have problems
uh
just oh wait am i frozen what happened
yeah what's going on uh
now my chat's still talking uh give me a
second
why am i frozen hold on chat we're
getting it i don't know what the heck is
going on but we're getting it
what um heck is going on
uh here we go no i'm still frozen
why am i frozen
uh i'm not really sure what's happening
here hold on
uh okay um
why does everything always go wrong like
in the finale
and chris i can't hear you anymore i
wasn't talking
what's the point i don't know i don't
know why this is uh
not working out you add a new screen to
your
that's that's what i'm that's what i'm
trying to do
um
i'm still i'm just frozen yeah
uh i'm present guys i'm gonna
i'm gonna come right back i'm gonna end
the stream